Alright, everybody, so here is example number two, silver here. You can see we have this low. We had a market structure shift here and consecutive bearish candles or down close candles is your order block. If I mark the order block like that, you can clearly see that price ripped through the order block, taking out the order block liquidity. And afterwards, we had a reclaim and then a retest. I'm looking at a S100 and you can see that price has went up.
like that. So you can clearly see that we took our sell side here, right? And they made it look
so obvious. The sell side was taken. We had a market structure shift. So a lot of
ACG traders would try to go along either of this fair value gap or this entire auto
bar. But what happens? Price takes out the slow. And you might be asking me that what about
other training strategies. Now we are doing this without bias. Okay. So this is a no daily
bus strategy. That is when we're going to use this method and it's not going to happen
all the time. Most of the time or some sometimes it's going to react off this where we
go up and go up. It's not going to be a case where it happens every time. But if you see a pattern
like this where you have a sweep, right? And let's say your initial entry was here and you
lost the rate. But you can do is look for this pattern where price reclaims itself,
like that closes above it. So this is very important closes above it. And you have like a
a target level. This could be a take profit one. This could be your take profit two.
Let's move on to another example.